KATIE STECKLES: My favorite
number is 27.
It's always been my favorite
number, even before I was a
mathematician--
before I was properly a
mathematician, I guess.
Because 3 has got--
3 is a magic number,
in some sense.
It's got properties.
Like 3 add 3 was a bit boring.
3 times 3 still wasn't
quite good enough.
But then 3 to the power of 3
was like, that'll do me.
So I went for 27.
And I always had this idea that
being 27 would be, like,
I would totally have
everything in my
life sorted by then.
The year when I was 27
would be awesome--
a brilliant year.
I have recently turned 27.
Things are going pretty well,
I'd say, probably.
3 is sort of the first proper
number, really.
Like 1's nonsense.
1 doesn't really do anything.
2 is just there.
And then 3--
3 is when you start to
really get number-y.
3 crops up in a lot of places.
It has got quite a lot of
stuff related to it.
BRADY HARAN: Then why isn't
3 your favorite number?
KATIE STECKLES: Well,
it was, at first.
But I realized that I was
quite derivative.
And that pretty much everyone
who realized how good 3 was
would just be like, oh, yeah,
my favorite number's 3.
So I decided to power it up
and go for 3 to the 3.
I recently found out that 27 is
a self-locating number in
the expansion of pi.
It obviously starts with the
3, but then the bit we're
interested in is the decimal.
So it's like 3, 141,
and so on.
So these are just the decimal
digits of pi.
But if I count along here--
and of course, like all good
computer scientists, I start
counting at 0--
occasionally I'll find numbers
which match up with their own
position in this decimal
expansion.
So 6--
there is a number which starts
at its position 6 in here.
So if I carry on numbering
these, this doesn't actually
happen for that many numbers.
And in fact, if I get
here, I've got 27.
And the 27th digit there is the
beginning of the number 27
here in this decimal
expansion.
And in fact, the next time that
will happen is at some
point in pi, we'll
get to this.
And in fact, that digit there
is digit number 13,598.
That is next time that
that will happen.
So 27--
pretty special.
BRADY HARAN: What'd you do
for your 27th birthday?
KATIE STECKLES: I had a party
and invited all my friends.
And we played board games.
BRADY HARAN: What games?
KATIE STECKLES: We had a
Rubik's-cube-themed board game.
We had some maths-- we
had Set, which is
a maths card game.
And various other fairly nerdy,
serious board games.
But it was pretty good.
We hired out a room in a pub and
just took over the room.